brothers and sisters I need your help
today because there are reverts around
the world who live alone who don't know
how to praise Salah but want to learn we
print and send them directly to their
houses most of us have a wealth to teach
10 people how to praise Allah just 100
pounds equals 10 salamats click the
button or the link and donate now
[Music]
oh
every night in my dreams I pray that I
see you
that is
[Music]
far across the distance
and spaces between
Fatima listen we're running late I need
you to go in my bedroom and in the
second drawer is the ribbon please bring
it with you when you come to the hall
okay salmon
Joshua with beautiful lashes thank you
so much take care from Mom outside no
wonder they're beautiful
come in
look at you mashallah you look so
beautiful well I just want to find out
one thing were you this nervous when you
got married to Bubba of course I was I
was just 18. I finished my a levels and
Bubba he had just qualified at UCL and
it was Ramadan and you know what your
dad's like when he hasn't had food oh my
God so bubbles like this in his younger
years too listen I've gotta go your
sister's on the phone but don't forget
to pray okay Mom I don't have makeup
artist just took a lot of time I'll pray
later your prayer oh pray later
okay I'll pray
it's taken two hours to do your makeup
you're really gonna take it off no no
way no one needs to know I'll pray later
okay
Picture Perfect whose mouth three two
one cheese yes can just a bit to the
left
thank you can have the kind of the Grim
just put his arm her hand on on the
right shoulder thank you
there's a bit to the left now everyone
stands a bit to the left to pick the
perfect five four three two one thank
you excellent
thank you
whose mouths five four three two one
my baby
before smiling please final last picture
thank you again just once more
dance
very cool
that is her heartbeat not every wedding
has a happy ending Zara said she would
pray later but who told her she was
promised later let me tell you about a
creation of Allah there's a group of
angels that when Allah created them they
began prostrating to him and they will
prostrate until he gives the command for
them to rise up on the day of judgment
and they will say to him we did not
worship you properly
what is our excuse Allah says in the
Quran by time man is surely in loss
except those who believed and did
righteous Deeds
if only we gave the same amount of
attention to our Salah the same
importance to our Salah as we do this
powder on our faces we would surely be
winners the most important day of your
life is not your wedding day it's the
day you meet Allah and that day it
doesn't matter whether you're wearing
makeup or not
at Salam our aim is to reconnect the
world back to Allah through Salah and
that's why we've launched our projects
the LA plus.com you can learn how to
praise the Lord the conditions of Salah
how to do would do how to memorize the
Quran or order a guided promo you can
easily because the line structure on our
website with quick easy steps and that
instructor can come and teach you how to
pray one to one check out solarplus.com
and reconnect to Allah